in the social Center of Buenos Aires on
Saturday night
prices across Argentina are skyrocketing
but here it does not seem like country
is an economic
turmoila Salvia promotes a theater play
on the street she says there is one
reason that explains it all
owed to have fun we all
we all sad news price increases every
day if you have a little bit of money
the only thing you want to do is go out
Argentina is struggling with massive
foreign debt while domestic prices for
goods and services continue to rise
most analysts agree it's a strategy of
printing money to finance spending that
it's a main reason why most economic
measures fail for many people in
Argentina living with high inflation
means heading to the shops to buy
groceries after payday before the prices
start going up or learning to live
without certain products but for others
who have some money left over there is
no point in Saving and that's one of the
reasons why the restaurants and theaters
in the city are full
is a historic barium Buenos Aires it's
been open since the 1930s Julian Diaz
bought it a few years ago he says that
in spite of the economic struggles he
continues to believe in the country
inflation is the biggest challenge we
have because we change prices every
month but if the price goes up
alarmingly we have to get it off the
menu we learn to be creative so we can
find ways to make it work
Trends in the capital
before Argentina's 4 who now represents
over 40 percent of the population it's a
different story
protests like this one are ongoing in
the capital every week
analysts say latest figures show people
have stopped saving
the capital is an area where the middle
class is larger and those people have
stopped saving savings are going down
but consumption is continuing in
Argentina a salary is around 500 even if
you make 700 then you go out and you
spend it
Argentina is a country where people have
gotten used to living in crisis and many
have become experts on how to outwit
economic instability
although the impact is falling mainly on
those with greater economic needs
there is Aires
foreign